[Aplausos]
[Música]
sabéis que el ceo de google sundar
pichai nació en la india pero esperad un
momento porque el ceo de microsoft satya
nadella también es de la línea ya que no
adivináis donde nació el ceo de adobe
shantanu narayen exacto también es de la
india vamos a decirlo claro el día está
conquistando el silicon valley en
realidad podemos decir que india está
conquistando la industria del software
en todo el mundo por ejemplo cuál es la
empresa de servicios de tecnología más
grande del planeta alguno pensará en
accenture o alguna presida verdad error
craso error la respuesta correcta es
tata computing services y si también son
de la india y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando ahora la india pero
para ser un país pobre pues si tenéis
razón dos tercios de los indios viven
por debajo de la línea de la pobreza 73
millones de indios están en la pobreza
extrema 68 millones viven en chabolas y
sólo el 8% tiene un título universitario
en comparación con el 34% de eeuu de
hecho el 25 por ciento de la población
india son analfabetos pero la realidad
es que hay dos indias totalmente
distintas por un lado tenemos la india
normal es decir la pobre y dentro de esa
india hay otra india es la que podríamos
llamar tech india es decir la india
tecnológica sitech india fuera un país
independiente sería tan rico como
alemania tendría un pib n 177 mil
millones de dólares y una población de 4
millones de personas que son los
empleados en este sector
[Música]
tan solo cuatro empresas de cs infosys
hcl y white pro tienen todas juntas una
plantilla de más de un millón de
personas y si estas cuatro empresas son
indias es más si alguno de vosotros
trabaja en el sector y te estoy seguro
de que en algún momento ha estado
trabajando con alguien de la india a
estas alturas supongo que tendréis un
montón de preguntas con un país tan
pobre ha podido desarrollar una
industria tan compleja como la del
software con un país con una tasa de
analfabetismo tan alta ha podido
convertirse en el segundo mayor
exportador de software del mundo hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el camino equivocado cuando pensamos en
la política india pensamos en mahatma
gandhi pero en realidad ese gandhi fue
asesinado en 1948 una de las figuras más
importantes de nuestra historia no es
grande o al menos no es ese gandhi sino
jaguar la jal
este señor fue el primer primer ministro
de india bajo su gobierno
india aprobó su constitución y se
convirtió en un país independiente
ya en los años 50 en eeuu tenía una
visión muy clara para su país quería
convertirlo en el líder de fabricación
de ordenadores pensando bien era los
años 50 la revolución de los ordenadores
se estaba empezando y todavía había una
ventana de oportunidad para que un país
nuevo compitiera con occidente la
pregunta es y eso cómo se hace pues bien
en lugar de seguir el modelo británico
en eeuu decidió imitar la política de
stalin
esto no significa que india se
convirtiera en un país comunista
sí es cierto que tomaron muchos
elementos de la unión soviética
especialmente dos los planes
quinquenales y la prohibición de
importaciones india quería proteger a
sus empresas locales y así es como
surgieron grandes gigantes nacionales
como está y si hablamos del mismo 'tata'
que fabrica los coches también es el
tapa que creó las primeras aerolíneas de
la india y el mismo tata que creó una
empresa de ordenadores la tata computing
services 6
[Música]
a la vez el gobierno decidió apostar por
la educación superior en los años 60
ella construyó montones de los llamados
institutos indios de tecnología de
repente cientos de indios estaban
preparados para trabajar en esa nueva
industria de los ordenadores el problema
el problema es que no había empresas
para contratarles con la excepción de
thatta apenas había grandes empresas
tecnológicas en la india como habían
prohibido a las exportaciones de
tecnología ninguna fábrica podía comprar
los materiales necesarios para poder
fabricar ordenadores para que os hagáis
una idea en 1970 india tenía únicamente
150 ordenadores en todo el país y esos
ordenadores estaban importados por ibm
que había logrado sortear un sinfín de
regulaciones y es en ese momento cuando
aparece la segunda protagonista de
nuestra historia
pero no no no estamos hablando de ese
handy sino de indira gandhi de la
primera ministra de la india durante los
años 60 y 70 y no está gandín no tenía
nada que ver con mahatma en realidad
indira gandhi era la hija del primer
protagonista de nuestra historia el
señor negro pues bien indira gandhi se
dio cuenta de que había 150 ordenadores
que habían cruzado la frontera y que
creéis que hizo o dios mío
alguien está comprando ordenadores
extranjeros qué escándalo que eso
significa que no estamos regulando lo
suficiente y así es como en 1978 un día
sacó una nueva ley que hacía que
importar ordenadores fuera prácticamente
imposible
[Música]
obviamente a ibm le faltó tiempo para
marcharse de la india pocos meses
después de que se aprobara esta ley y
diréis esto sería un buen momento para
las empresas locales verdad pues no para
nada todo lo contrario esa ventana de
oportunidad se terminó de cerrar en ese
momento la posible industria tecnológica
india desapareció en ese momento
mientras el resto del mundo estaba
demasiado ocupado comprando ordenadores
japoneses y estadounidenses sin embargo
todo cambió en el año 1982 porque ahora
mismo lo vamos a
[Música]
aprendiendo de los errores el año 1982
será recordado en la india como el año
en el que se celebrarán los juegos
asiáticos algo así como los juegos
olímpicos pero solo para asia y el
organizador de estos juegos eran nada
más y nada menos llegan
[Música]
pero no no s gandhi
y ese otro tampoco en este caso hablamos
de este de radio gandia de nuevo no
tenía ningún parentesco con mahatma
gandhi pero era el hijo de indira gandhi
tb que en india se toman muy en serio
toda la familia política sin embargo
este gandhi era totalmente distinto de
su madre y gandhi juniors era un amante
de la tecnología y quería usar los
ordenadores para sus juegos asiáticos es
decir para programar las distintas
competiciones para registrar los
resultados los anuncios etcétera y ahí
es cuando se dio cuenta de la realidad
apenas había ordenadores en todo el país
esto fue toda una epifanía para él así
que tan pronto como llegó al primer
ministro dio un giro de 180 grados a la
política del país
[Música]
lo primero que hizo fue quitar todos los
aranceles y todas las prohibiciones a la
importación de ordenadores un día para
otros los indios podían comprar peces
siempre y cuando los usaran para
desarrollar software como buen amante de
la tecnología gandhi se había dado
cuenta de una cosa ya era muy tarde para
que la india compitiera fabricando
hardware pero en ese momento había una
nueva ventana de oportunidad una nueva
revolución que estaba empezando cuál era
la revolución del software y vaya sí dio
resultado
harto de pagar una fortuna a tus
programadores en eeuu bienvenido a
aquellas universidades de lujo
trabajadores cualificados y todo eso por
menos del 20% de los costes laborales en
los jjoo s todo eso y más en que ya
tenemos cero aranceles para la
importación de ordenadores ni siquiera
necesitas asociarte con un partner local
para establecerse aquí incluso tenemos
nuestro propio satélite para que todas
sus oficinas en california se comuniquen
con agencia exenciones fiscales
disponibles consultas contable indio
para más información únete a la
revolución
compact ya lo ha hecho también texas
instruments incluso ibm ha regresado al
país todos ahorran costes ya que ya
llama ahora al teléfono que aparece en
pantalla
de repente india pasa de tener menos de
1000 ordenadores en 1978 a más de 80.000
en 1990 empresas como tapa computer
services son hindustán con pieters
trabajaban en casi todos los proyectos
de gigantes como hewlett packard y el
gobierno estaba encantado antes que
muchos países occidentales ellos estaban
siendo pioneros en cosas como máquinas
de voto electrónico banca electrónica o
incluso venta de billetes de trenes
electrónica de repente el mundo entero
miraba a la india como el lugar donde
encontrar programadores
la revolución de los ordenadores llega
indian más o menos por estas fechas es
cuando nace la asociación nacional de
empresas de software y servicios la
patronal de tec india
esta empresa se ha convertido en un logo
importantísimo en la india y ha sido
fundamental en la liberalización
tecnológica de este país pero vale ya sé
lo que estará pensando algunos porque
siempre hay un listillo que lo dice en
los comentarios
fonseca como se te ve el plumero de
verdad nos vas a decir que todo ha sido
tan sencillo liberaliza en un sector y
pum todos felices pues no tenéis razón
hay una pequeña trampa en esta historia
os acordáis de todos esos recién
graduados que se habían mucho de
informática pero que no tenían empresas
indias donde trabajar pues muchos de
ellos se fueron a silicon valley
[Música]
y tiempo fueron ascendiendo en sus
empresas hasta tener una influencia real
pues bien estos indoamericanos fueron
los que ayudaron al gobierno indio a
diseñar una legislación a la medida de
las empresas tecnológicas y también
convencieron a los directivos
estadounidenses para que abrieran
oficinas ya que esto explica por ejemplo
por qué india construyó todos esos
satélites para que las oficinas inglesas
y estadounidenses se comunicarán con la
india a ningún político quiero trabajar
en software en aquellos años se le
habría ocurrido esa idea y así es como
se creó todo un círculo virtuoso para la
tecnología en la india incluso la crisis
financiera de los años 90 con la mega
devaluación de la ruta incluida sirvió
para consolidar aún más el poder de
pequeña
[Música]
si el resto del país sufrió una
inflación galopante pero las empresas de
software eran más competitivas debido al
cambio de divisa para que sabéis una
idea en el año 2000 la industria del
software india bari a más de 5.000
millones de dólares pero esperad un
momento porque todavía no habéis visto
nada todavía no hemos llegado al
auténtico punto de inflexión en nuestra
historia el momento en el que te cambia
se convirtió en el líder global del
software ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
el efecto 2000 si tenéis más de 30 años
seguro que os acordáis bien de lo que os
voy a contar recordáis el efecto 2000 en
el año 1990 muchos pensaban que el
cambio de siglo traería algo así como el
fin del mundo y lo decían de forma no
irónica
panel del senado describe el y2k o
efecto 2000 como una crisis mundial
es uno de los eventos más potencialmente
devastadores que américa se ha
encontrado nunca veréis los primeros
ordenadores no tenían discos duros muy
grandes así que los informáticos usaban
solo los dos últimos dígitos del año
para representar el año en el que
estaban por ejemplo en lugar de poner
1960 ponían 60 eso significa que el año
00 podría ser el año 2000 o el año 1900
es decir que en el momento en el que el
calendario marcará 1 de enero de 00
todos los sistemas informáticos del
mundo colapsaría
y diréis y todo esto que tiene que ver
con la india pues como os dijimos al
principio india no empezó a tener
ordenadores hasta los años 80 es decir
que todos sus sistemas ya contaban con
equipos más modernos que no tenían ese
problema de los dos dígitos es decir que
mientras el mundo desarrollado podría
estar impactado la india estaba libre
del efecto 2000 y eso les dio una
ventaja temporal para poder ayudar a
todos los sistemas informáticos del
mundo a solucionar el efecto 2000 es
decir podemos decir que te quería salvó
al mundo y ganó una auténtica fortuna
con ello una ninja por la amenaza del
efecto 2000 pero cómo ocurrió todo esto
hay varios factores primero india estaba
produciendo por aquel entonces y en mil
nuevos graduados de informática cada
ángel sueldo de un programador indio era
un sexto de lo que cobraba su homólogo
en eeuu
además de kindia estaba más que lista
para mandar todos los comerciales que
hicieran falta a los países
desarrollados acordáis de nash con la
patronal de pekín después se pasearon
por todas las ferias comerciales de
burgos oslo londres/nueva york y san
josé para que os hagáis una idea solo en
el año 1998 el efecto 2000 supuso el 40
por ciento de los ingresos de
para entonces india ya se había
convertido en la referencia mundial del
software durante la siguiente década los
servicios de haití se han expandido
hasta cubrir los procesos más complejos
arquitectura de software y más de
business integration prácticamente no
hay una empresa de informática que no
tenga una oficina grande en la india y
en la última década de kindia ha sumado
más de 10.000 empresas nuevas y dos
millones de trabajadores más pero
esperad un momento porque aquí es donde
termina la parte bonita de nuestro contó
de hadas ahora vamos a ver la cara más
oscura de kindia atentos
[Música]
los países opuestos si hay una cosa mala
por la que india es famosa es por su
sistema de castas como sabéis la clase
en la acción no nace es muy importante
en este país y pekín ya es la mejor
muestra un país rico dentro de uno pobre
la pregunta es y qué pasa con la otra
india pues por sorprendente que parezca
sólo el 10% de la población tiene acceso
a internet en las zonas rurales
este número baja hasta el 3%
[Música]
por supuesto que trabajar en tech india
es un auténtico lujo un programador
normal puede ganar un sueldo de unos
diez mil dólares al año esto puede
parecer es una miseria pero pensar y
esto sigue siendo la india según
espadista puntocom si vivís en una
ciudad como bangalore o dice alquilar un
piso por menos de 200 dólares al mes así
que si los informáticos en la india
viven bien solo el llamado corredor de
mangalore tiene 67 mil empresas y eso
incluye esos gigantes indios como
infosys mein trick o white pro pero
entrar en tech india requiere un nivel
educativo muy alto y recluído y un
capital social inimaginable para la
mayor parte de los indios
[Música]
ser informático es el auténtico sueño
indio pensar que no sólo se trata de
conseguir un buen trabajo en mangalore
también es un pasaje de avión para poder
trabajar en el extranjero
el mundo entero está deseando contratar
indios
japón está desesperado por las tx indias
morderán el anzuelo el visado alemán
fracasa a la hora de tentar a los
expertos en it e indios para que os
hagáis una idea en sillicon valley el 50
por ciento de los trabajadores
inmigrantes es los que toman la famosa
visa h-1b son indios y lo mismo ocurre
en seattle donde amazon y microsoft
tienen sus oficinas centrales pero
incluso ahí se mantiene el sistema de
castas según el quality labs las
multinacionales estadounidenses como
facebook amazon o microsoft están
discriminando a los indios de las castas
más bajas sin embargo a pesar de todo
eso el sueño de cualquier indio sigue
siendo entrar en pekín
y ticket de salida la aldea india donde
toda la familia tiene un ingeniero por
ejemplo en una aldea que se llama
pazguato lee en el norte de la india la
comunidad se llevó a organizar para dar
ayudas a los niños para que pudieran
estudiar en esas universidades
tecnológicas los padres invierten los
ahorros de toda una vida e incluso piden
créditos en el banco para poder pagar a
un coach que ayude a los niños a pasar
los exámenes de ingreso y solo en 2017
20 chicos de esta aldea fueron aceptados
en una de estas universidades pero a
pesar de estos esfuerzos las castas más
pobres suponen todavía sólo el 9 por
ciento de los estudiantes
y de nuevo qué pasa con el resto de la
india porque no crecen tanto como otilia
pues lo cierto es que fuera de los
ordenadores y del software india es uno
de los países más proteccionistas que
existen eso y el paraíso de la
burocracia según el índice de facilidad
para hacer negocios india está junto a
arabia saudita o ucrania por ejemplo
cada producto que se vende en este país
tiene un impuesto distinto a veces
incluso distintos modelos del mismo
producto pueden tener univa distintos
hay barreras al mercado incluso dentro
del propio país por ejemplo si quieres
pasar de un estado a otro encontraras
largas colas de camiones y dirás por qué
pues porque están esperando a pasar la
aduana y cada vez que pasan a otro
estado dentro del mismo país otra vez
les toca pasar por la aduana y diréis y
qué pasa con los aranceles pues si los
ordenadores se pueden importar sin
muchos problemas pero no podemos decir
lo mismo del resto de productos desde
medicinas hasta ropa india tiene uno de
los aranceles más altos del mundo y si
alguien se esperaba que el gobierno de
extrema derecha en andhra modi ibaka
podéis seguir esperando ya planea poner
aranceles extra y barreras de mercado a
300 productos de importación en los
últimos dos años
amazon walmart se han convertido en el
objetivo de la furia tener en 'gara'
modi al igual que gandhi hizo todo lo
posible por echar a ibm del país móvil
parece obsesionado con hacer lo mismo
con amazon incluso hay un debate serio
en este país para echar a este i comerç
del país y que no puedo perder su
mercado y en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo esto es lo que está
ocurriendo en la emoción la
confederación de comerciantes de india
quiere una prohibición de siete días
para amazon por violar la regla del país
de origen así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros porque la india no
extiende las reglas de tequila al resto
del país o tal vez el éxito de tec india
es sólo una burbuja que tarde o temprano
terminará estallando podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
mientras tanto no olvidéis que aquí en
visual político sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribirse a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo
y hasta pronto
[Música]